- I got real lucky.
My low was being born.
Meaning I was born
in the Soviet Union,
a shit place with the worst, the
worst place on Earth to be born
in 1975 or minimally one of the
worst places and definitely the
worst place at scale to be born
in the world was where
I was born. Right?
We didn't have shit and so
I immigrated to the U.S.,
we had nothing.
I was poor.
I didn't speak English.
I went outside in
Dover, New Jersey,
I never talk about this,
I was picked on heavily.
Kids forced me to drink
pee out of a Pepsi can.
I was 4-foot-11 my
freshman year of high school.
Not good.
I was short,
I couldn't, you know,
my home, my infrastructure.
Me! Like my life.
Three of my four grandparents
died before I was born.
Right, so I didn't have that.
My dad worked every minute,
I never saw him
because we had to
make it in America.
So, no dad in the equation.
Had the best mom of all time so
that equally is why I'm here.
Have the greatest
mom of all time.
So, you know, and so my,
I have a chip on my shoulder.
I'm an underdog.
I wasn't born in
this awesome country.
Everybody here had
quicker head start than I did,
you know what I mean?
And so being an immigrant
and being small.
Like I think, I genuinely
believe when I think about it
being an immigrant
went away eventually,
right, by third grade,
I was American.
It was, you know,
for boys, you know,
being under 5-foot
going into high school,
that's some good adversity.
You know?
And then
manufacturing it, right?
I love underdogs.
When the Yankees and the
Rangers won championships,
I stopped being a fan.
I'm actually anti-bandwagon.
You know like like
I don't want to,
when my teams win
I abandon them.
Like, literally.
Like literally I have not
watched a full Yankee or Ranger
game since they won
their championships.
But I love the Jets and Knicks.
I'm hardwired for the underdog.
I hated Tiger Woods when he
was America's sweetheart.
He goes in the shitter,
I love Tiger Woods.
I hated Kobe Bryant when he was
the best basketball
player in the world.
The last two years I loved
Kobe 'cause he's finished.
I loved it.
Like that's who
I am so my hardwiring,
my ethos, who I am is
adversity, is underdog.
I won the wine world.
I won the wine business world.
How did I do, what
did I do with that?
I left it and came in to an
industry where I was nothing.
Everybody made fun of
me, I'm Twitter boy.
I have a lot of
Twitter followers.
I'm gonna start an agency and
now I'm fucking sticking it to
their faces, right,
and now I'm almost done.
And another five or seven years
I'll build the undisputed great
agency of this generation and
you know how
I'm gonna handle that?
Not by cashing in and
fucking laying on a beach.
I'm gonna do what I always do,
which is walk directly away from
it and start a new challenge
where I'm the underdog.
Wait, he can't do that.
That has nothing to do,
don't forget what I did.
I went from the wine retail
business to the advertising
agent, that had no
connection and so,
you know, I don't know I'm gonna
go win a fucking
Golden Globe or something.